Special planting days were recently held at
Silverstream Reserve as part of
Matariki Tu Rākau.
Local members of the RSA, joined with Council
Staff, Te Uru Rākau Forestry New Zealand,
the Silverstream Reserve Advisory Group and
other volunteers to plant 660 Kanuka seedlings
over two days.
Matariki Tu Rākau is a partnership between
Te Uru Rākau - Forestry New Zealand, and local
communities to plant trees to recognise the
service of men and women of the New Zealand
Defence Forces and mark the 100-year anniversary
of the end of the First World War.
It’s part of a wider government initiative
to plant one billion trees over the next 10 years.
The trees have been planted in a grid
to represent soldiers standing in formation.
In the future, seating will be installed to
create a beautiful space to sit and reflect.
The plantings are just one small part of the
Silverstream Reserve restoration project,
which aims to return approximately 52 hectares
to native planting over the coming decades.
In just the next year alone, volunteers and
the Council are hoping to plant 2000 additional trees.